welcome back to las vegas now so it's
been a little chilly here in vegas and
if you are itching for that warmer
weather or want to be transported to a
tropical vacation you can do just that
with a fresh cocktail from boom bang
find foods and cocktails and joining me
today is beverage director christina cox
to give us a taste of the new drink menu
thanks for being here yeah thank you for
having me so unfortunately i have not
been into boom bang yet and i hear that
i'm missing out because i heard that
food is just absolutely delicious talk
about the vibe and you know what you can
expect when you walk in oh well it's a
super laid back place it's a classy
place really great cocktails amazing
food
the chef owners are just fabulous people
very lovely it's a really well
warm welcoming place well and speaking
of warm welcoming we're kind of getting
into the summer vibes with these new
cocktails so tell me what we're going to
make today and we'll we'll see how my
bartending skills are
um yeah so today we're going to make the
chief walk
it's a
tiki polynesian cocktail you might see
it a little bit more on menus right now
and it's kind of a fun
take me away vacation kind of cocktail
we have some tropical music playing here
on a hulu oh yes and get down with a
good drink so let's get right to it
let's make this okay awesome so we're
gonna start with some lemon juice okay
you want to do that yeah i'll do that
lemon juice pour it to the top okay
just a little splash here
perfect
and we're going to do
a lot of orange juice okay and so here
at boom bang
we um we try to stay you know
low uh waist at boom bang and shoulders
yeah i'm learning today okay and we do a
lot of cocktails that have orange rinds
in it and so instead of just you know
getting rid of the oranges we actually
made this cocktail to use the orange
juice oh for all the oranges we use for
the orange rinds for the cocktails oh
that's amazing yeah okay we're getting
tropical vibes here what's next so we're
gonna do one ounce of this so you're
gonna flip it the other way yeah i'm
learning here this is one ounce okay and
what was this this is a petite cane
syrup this is something we make in-house
uh it's a really thick syrup i'm
guessing it's pretty sweet right gives
it that sweet touch yeah yeah it is i'm
all about the sugar here okay what do we
have next and we've got some passion
fruit okay fresh passion fruit one ounce
of that yes okay very good passion fruit
let's see how i'm doing here
maybe oh there we go it's really fresh
well this smells so good i really feel
like i'm on vacation especially with
this music we have going on okay on this
thing we have about a minute left so now
we're going to do our rum okay lots of
rum turn around oh yeah there we go we
need the bigger side of this okay lots
of room i should just dump this whole
thing in here mm-hmm let's do it should
a little more a little more
we're doing one and a half here okay
perfect now we're gonna give it a shake
gosh it smells good
give it a shot all right you're trusting
me yeah
yeah
all right i can't wait to try it okay is
that a good change yeah okay now we're
gonna open it okay we're just gonna pour
it right in there we're gonna garnish
with some
some pineapple leaves okay it's going
right
look at that
all right and then we're gonna go ahead
and put some oh yeah it's not complete
without a garnish right you have to have
the beautiful tiki garnishes okay oh
sorry
i'm too excited to drink it
and tell us the name of this one more
time you make it sound so good the
chifla poo sounds amazing this is just
one of a few new drinks that you guys
have at boom bang right yes so people
want to come by and come check out are
these drinks already on the menu they
are they're on the current menu we just
launched them beginning of the new year
so all right i'm going in for it let's
see how my bartending skills are here we
go
oh and you're seeing some pictures of
the rose show look you can feel like
you're on vacation right there
patio and i have to say i'm really proud
of my drink right here thank you for
teaching me this is absolutely delicious
thank you all right well thank you so
much and real quick where are you guys
located we're on the 2 15 and valley
birthday okay easy enough go escape on a
tropical vacation i'll just be here
sipping my drink thank you so much
all right las vegas i'll be right back